> E CKOFHING US RE KIM BRUNHUBEK
UKRAINE CA MNGON MIDTE
HEADF E TION OF IDT
WAYOR
A
U.S. HELP WILL KEE E CONGRESCHA
HERE HE WIRUSSIAHAS SHOWLI
>> WE NST AND WI
EANC WE AN WHATEVE
WORROFOU
IT, BUT IN THIS A ISNO S
WI RUSANERLIER HE
THE FIRST TI IN MONTHS ANDEMPHA
OFKRAINEWITHOUY AT THOUR
SS THE COUNTRY.
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE WAS THE
TARGETIN KNOCKED OUT
POWER OM W
I
RAM OVERD
OTP A MAVER DAM.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW ABOUTHE REO
ATTACK AND BIG MIGHTN? Reporter
THAT THE NUMBER AND
RUSSIAD T ON THE
ENER AS ABOUALMOST
TWO WHEN RUSSIRST
BEGATHY HEAVY TARGETING
RUCTURE.
HAVE BEEN  OSTEM
E SOUTH, THEAS
INTERCT  RUSANMISSILFI
ID GET
E REGION TT TRICITIFFERENT RNS
G BLUTS G
KY IS F  RAID SIRENS
TODAY AN
ROUND MISSIL POWER STATION IKYI.
HERE.
T URE IN
SO ORY WEMS TONG TS EN
AND SOME OF THSMLE
FIVE IN THE WEST OF THE COY,THER
SUPPLIES MAY NOT GET THROUGH
TY, SO THERE
ARE SHORTAR OFUKRA
SAYHEDOING
EVERYTHING THEY CA GET
ERNGNE,
ANENTIALG HECOTRREBUILREICKLY.
M IN THERRIVES OTHE DAM THAT IF
TAKE VITALLY NEEDEE
MI.
E THAT AT E ELECTRICALUN
LER THERE.
SO THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO KEETHER
UNTA ANDE SOREVIOUS COUPLE O
.
>> AND ONE OF THE OTHER BIG
WORRIEFRAN AREQUIT T DOES THAANC
>> Reporter: OF COSE BELARUS US
TO UKRAINE.
AS A POINT OINVA. NOBE
AND THE COMPLICAON, IF YOU
WILL, FOR THNS IHE COUNTRY AND .
ILL NEED TO DRAW
THEY T THEREAS UTH AND EAST A RC
NORTH.SO IT IS DISTRACTION THEE
ANO S ASHENKO
THE PRESIDENT OF SIGNED
A JOINT WITH VLADIMIR
TY  AJOINT FORCAT TKR
LILITARY EQUIPMENT A